excuse me mr. Pittman where is your
fiancee this Lyford Ellen when you were
out in public you are an ambassador for
this company and once you are CEO you
will be the face of this company you've
made up your mind I thought that I had
the thing that I think you need to learn
a little something about is the spirit
of the company I need you to deliver the
Christmas letters to uncle Zeke
see where it all began you want me to go
to snow falls what's this all about
anyway every Christmas
they write each other letter I want to
prove to my father that I can take care
of things on my own
[Music]
ah you need a cap hi I'm here to see the
owner Zeke he left town this morning did
he say how long he was going for sorry
what am I supposed to do hopefully he'll
show up tomorrow morning Wow there is
something it might be hot water bottle
weather forecast is calling for a major
snowstorm tonight I'm just gonna be
stuck here a little bit longer everybody
come on over to the fire and warm up you
folks stay in my room I have a couch in
my room I'd be happy to share it too
it's been a long time since I felt like
I could trust anyone
[Music]
[Applause]
why are you lying about who you are this
really is a friendly little town great
no one knows who I am they treat me like
a regular person and I'd like that
traditional friendship and well those
are the most important things that we
could ever give each other
[Music]
you
[Music]
you